[Musique]
connaissez-vous la animations oui
certainement vous connaissez puisqu'il
s'agit des films d'animation japonais
donc si vous aimez les films d'animation
japonais kan appelle aussi mon gars ou
plutôt animée nous vous proposons une
programmation spéciale le samedi 8
février à partir de 18h15
vous pourrez donc voir deux films pour 6
euros à 18h15
les enfants du temps où l'on voit deux
adolescents au daaka et ina qui font
face à un phénomène météorologique
extrême et comme l'avait fait déjà avec
excellent your name sortie fin 2016 donc
le régulateur makoto shinkai il nous
propose une très belle histoire dans
laquelle on parle d'amour d'écologie on
rit on pleure et c'est donc ce sera le
premier film à 18h15 le deuxième film
sera millenium actress s'éteint
un film de satoshi kon c'est un
chef-d'oeuvre inédit sur le grand écran
malheureusement satoshi kon nous a
quittés en 2010 et il nous a laissé pas
mal de films et c'est exceptionnel il
aurait commencé par travailler avec
otomo sur le phénoménal akira et ensuite
il a réalisé perfect blue millenium
actress tokyo godfathers enfin pas mal
de que des bons films
les deux films ce soir là seront à 6
euros les deux films vous pouvez
réserver vos places sur notre
billetterie en ligne sur cinéma grenier
à sel point com et si vous aimez japon
nous vous donnons rendez-vous aussi le
23 février avec une programmation
spéciale
[Musique]